what is clustering so we'll have a group
of people here hanging out at a
table or local coffee shop i'm guessing
coffee shops since they all have the
same mugs
and one of them is uh trying to figure
out what they're going to do i have 20
places to cover
in four days i guess he's going
traveling that sounds fun
one of those breeze through costa rica
or visiting the us
or going to to europe to go visit all
the highlights
so he's got 20 places he wants to go and
he wants to hit him in four days
very ambitious and how will i manage to
cover
all of them that's the question that
he's coming up how am i going to get to
all these different places in the
short time i have maybe he's a sales
team so he has 20 places he's got to do
demos for
you can make use of clustering by
grouping the places into
four clusters each of these clusters
will have places which are close by
so we're going to cluster them together
by what is closest to the other one
then each day you can visit one cluster
and cover all the places in the cluster
great that's a great idea you know if
you're going to hit four different
places
maybe you're going to cluster whatever
streets are closest together so you
don't have to travel spend all your time
traveling
the method of dividing the objects into
clusters which are similar between them
and are dissimilar to the objects
belonging to another cluster
so this is a formal definition of
clustering and we have here
what we call hierarchical clustering and
partial clustering
and we're going to go more into detail
on hierarchical clustering
and you'll see the difference between
the two where partial clustering doesn't
have
the descending graph it just has groups
of things
and under hierarchical clustering we're
going to go over agglomerative
and divisive and you can think of
agglomerative of
bringing things together and divisive as
dividing them apart
and then partial clustering the two most
common
ones are k-means that's probably the
most common use for partial clustering
and there's also fuzzy c
means and there's other ways of
clustering and other algorithms out
there but these are the two big
ones k means really being the most
common one used
but we're not going to dig too deep into
partial clustering because we're
studying
hierarchical clustering today so what is
clustering well the applications of
clustering are pretty numerous
we have things like customer
segmentation what people kind of belong
together how do we group them together
we have social network analysis so
social networks we might look at
sentiments what group of people like
something what group of people don't
like something
and then we can use that sentiments to
suggest new cells for them
you know this whole group is into harley
davidson motorcycles
so we cater to them to sell them
harley-davidson motorcycle parts and we
find out that people in that group also
like leather jackets
they also like motorcycle boots and they
like bandanas
my brother's into harley-davidson so
that's why i picked that kind of funny
example but you can kind of see we look
for similarities between these people
and then we group them together
accordingly
and that's a good sentimental clustering
is very common in so many things today
we want to know the sentiments on stocks
who is interested in stocks who's not
sentimental analysis we talked about
customer segmentation
in cells well we want to know what kind
of sentimental
view people have on different
restaurants if we're going to open up a
new restaurant or a new
putting stores in and of course city
planning a lot of this i just kind of
aimed at the city planning side
city planning is big with clustering we
want to cluster things together
so that they work we don't want to put a
industrial zone
in the middle of somebody's neighborhood
where they're not going to enjoy it
or have a commercial zone right in the
middle of the industrial zone where no
one's going to want to go
next to a factory to go eat a high-end
meal or dinner
so it's very big in city planning but
it's also very big in just
pre-processing data into other models
so when we're exploring data being able
to cluster things together
reveal things in the data we never
thought about and then once we have it
clustered we can put that into another
model to help us figure out what it is
we want for our solution
so let's go a little deeper into
hierarchical clustering
let's consider we have a set of cars and
we have a group similar
we want to group similar ones together
so below we have you'll see four
different cars down there
and we get two clusters of car types
sedan and suv
so if you're just looking at it you can
probably think oh yeah we'll put the
sedans together and the suvs together
and then at last we can group everything
into one cluster so we just have just
cars
so you can see as we have this we make a
nice little tree this is very
common when you see anybody talks about
hierarchical clustering this is usually
what you see and what comes out of it
we terminate when we are left with only
one cluster
so we have as you can see we bring them
all together we have one cluster we
can't bring it together anymore because
they're all together
hierarchical clustering is separating
data into different groups based
on some measure of similarity so we have
to find a way to measure
what makes them alike and what makes
them different agglomerative clustering
is known as a bottom up approach
remember i said think of that as
bringing things together
you see i think the latin term aglow is
together because you have your
glomerular rocks where all the different
pieces of rocks are in there
so we want to bring everything together
that's a bottom up and then
divisive is we're going to go from the
top down so we take one huge cluster
and we start dividing it up into two
clusters into three
four five and so on digging even deeper
into how
hierarchical clustering works let's
consider we have a few points on a plane
so this plane is 2d so we have an xy
coordinates kind of makes it easy
we're going to start with measure the
distance so we want to figure a way to
compute the distance between each point
each data point is a cluster of its own
remember if we're going from the bottom
up
agglomerative then we have each point
being its own
cluster we try to find the least
distance between two
data points to form a cluster and then
once we find those with the least
distance between them we start grouping
them together so we start forming
clusters of multiple points
this is represented in a tree-like
structure called dendogram so this is
another key word
dendogram and you can see it is it's
just a branch we've looked at before
and we do the second group the same so
it gets its own
dendrogram and the third gets its own
dendogram
and then we might group two groups
together so now those two groups are all
under one dendogram because they're
closer together than the p1 and p2
and then we terminate when we are left
with one cluster so we finally bring it
all together you can see on the right
how we've come up all the way up to the
top
whoops and we have the gray hierarchical
box coming in there and connecting them
so we have just one cluster and that's a
good place to terminate because
there is no way we can bring them
together any further so
how do we measure the distance between
the data points
i mean this is really where it starts
getting interesting up until now
you can kind of eyeball and say hey
these look together but when you have
thousands of data points how are we
going to measure those distances and
there is
a lot of ways to get the distance
measure so let's go and take a look at
that
distance measures will determine the
similarity between two elements and it
will influence the shape of the clusters
and we have euclidean distance measure
we have squared euclidean distance
measure which is almost the same thing
but with less computations
and we have the manhattan distance
measure which will give you slightly
different results
and we have the cosine distance measure
which again is very similar to the
euclidean playing with triangles
and sometimes it can compute faster
depending on what kind of data you're
looking at
so let's start with the clition distance
measure the most common is we want to
know the distance between the two points
so if we have point p
and point q the euclidean distance is
the ordinary straight line
it is the distance between the two
points in euclidean space
and you should recognize d equals in
this case we're going to sum
all the points so if there was more than
one point we could figure out the
distance to the not more than one points
this is the sum of more than two
dimensions
so we can have the distance between each
of the different dimensions
squared and that will give us and then
take the square root of that and that
gives us the actual distance between
them
and they should look familiar from
euclidean geometry maybe you haven't
played too much with multiple dimensions
so the summation
symbol might not look familiar to you
but it's pretty straightforward as you
add the distance
between each of the two different points
squared so if your y
difference was 2 minus 1 squared would
be
2 and then you take the difference
between the x
again squared and if there was a z
coordinates it would be
you know z1 minus z2 squared and then
take the square root of that and sum it
all or
sum it all together and then take the
square root of it so to make it compute
faster
since the difference in distances
whether one is farther apart or closer
together than the other
we can do what's called the squared
euclidean distance measurement
this is identical to the euclidean
measurement but we don't take the square
root at the end there's no reason to
it certainly gives us the exact distance
but as far as doing calculations as to
which one's bigger or smaller than the
other one
it won't make a difference so we'll just
go with the so we just get rid of that
that final square root computes faster
and it gives us the
pretty much the euclidean squared
distance on there now
the manhattan distance measurement is a
simple
sum of horizontal and vertical
components or the distance between two
points measured along
axes at right angles now this is
different because
you're not looking at the direct line
between them and
in certain cases the individual
distances
measured will give you a better result
now generally that's not true most times
you go with the euclidean squared method
because that's very fast and easy to see
but the manhattan distance is you
measure just the y
value and you take the absolute value of
it and you measure just the x difference
you take the absolute value of it and
just the z and if you had more
you know different dimensions in there a
b c d e f
however many dimensions you would just
take the absolute value of the
difference of those dimensions
and then we have the cosine distance
similarity
measures the angle between the two
vectors and as you can see
as the two vectors get further and
further apart the cosine distance
gets larger so it's another way to
measure the distance
very similar to the euclidean so you're
still looking at the same kind of
measurement
so should have a similar result as the
first two but keep in mind the manhattan
will have a very different
result and you can end up with a bias
with the manhattan if your data
is very skewed if one set of values is
very large
and another set of values is very small
but that's a little bit beyond the scope
of this it's just important to know that
about the manhattan distance
so let's dig into the agglomerative
clustering and agglometric clustering
begins with each element as a separate
cluster
and then we merge them into a larger
cluster how do we represent a cluster of
more than one point
so we're going to kind of mix the
distance together with the actual
agglomerative and see what that looks
like and
we're actually going to have three key
questions that are going to be answered
here
so how do we represent a cluster more
than one point
so we want to look at the math what it
looks like mathematically and
geometrically
how do we determine the nearness of
clusters
when to stop combining clusters always
important to have your
computer script or your whatever you're
working on have a termination point so
it's not in
going on internally we've all done that
if you do any kind of computer
programming or writing of script
let's assume that we have six data
points in a euclidean space
so again we're dealing with x y and z in
this case just
x and y so how do we represent a cluster
more than one point
let's take a look at that and first
we're going to make use of centroids
very common terminology in a lot of
machine learning languages when we're
grouping things together
so we're going to make use of centroids
which is the average of its points
and you can see here we're going to take
the 1 2 and the 2
1 and we're going to group them together
because they're close
and if we were looking at all the points
we look for those that are closest
and start with those and we're going to
take those two we're going to compute a
point in the middle
and we'll give that point 1 5 1.5 1.5
and that's going to be the centroid of
those two points and next we start
measuring like another group of points
we've got four one five zero when
they're pretty close together
so we'll go ahead and set up a centroid
of those two points in this case it
would be the
4.5 and 0.5 would be the
measurements on those two points and
once we have the centroid of the two
groups we find out that the next
closest point to a centroid is over on
the left
and so we're going to take this and say
oh zero 0 is closest to the
1.5 1.5 centroid so let's go ahead
and group that together and we compute a
new centroid based on those three points
so now we have a centroid of 1.1 or 1
comma 1.
and then we also do this again with the
last point the 5 3 and it computes into
the first group
and you can see our dendrogram on the
right is growing
so we have each of these points are
become connected and we start grouping
them together
and finally we get a centroid of that
group two and then finally the last
thing we want to do is combine the two
groups by their centroids and you can
see here we end up with one large group
and it'll have its own centroid although
usually they don't compute the last
centroid we just put them all together
so when do we stop combining clusters
well hopefully it's pretty obvious to
you
in this case when they all got to be one
but there are actually many
approaches to it so first pick a number
of clusters
k up front and this is done in the fact
that we don't want to look at
200 in clusters we only want to look at
the top five clusters or something like
that
so we decide the number of clusters
required in the beginning and we
terminate when we reach the value
k so if you looked back on our
clustering let me just go back a couple
screens
you'll see how we clustered these all
together and we might
want just the two clusters and so we
look at just the top two
or maybe we only want three clusters and
so we would compute
which one of these has a wider spread to
it or something like that there's other
computations to know
how to connect them and we'll look at
that in just a minute but to note that
when we pick the k
value we want to limit the information
that's coming in
so that can be very important especially
if you're feeding it into another
algorithm that requires three values or
you set it to four values and you need
to know that value coming in
so we might take the clustering and say
okay only
three clusters that's all we want for k
so the possible challenges
this only makes sense when we know the
data well so when you're clustering with
k
clusters you might already know that
domain and know that that makes sense
but if you're exploring brand new data
you might have no idea how many clusters
you really need to explore that data
with
let's consider the value of k to be 2.
so in this case in our previous example
we stop and we are left with
two clusters and you can see here that
this is where they came together the
best
while still keeping separate the data
the second approach is stop when the
next merge would create a cluster with
low cohesion so we keep clustering until
the next merge of clusters creates a bad
cluster low cohesion set up on there
that means the point is so close to
being between two clusters it doesn't
make sense to bring them together
but how is cohesion defined oh let's dig
a little deeper into cohesion
the diameter of a cluster so we're
looking at the actual diameter of our
cluster
and the diameter is the maximum distance
between any pair of points
in the cluster we terminate when the
diameter of a new cluster exceeds the
threshold
so as that diameter gets bigger and
bigger we don't want the two circles or
clusters to overlap
and we have radius of a cluster radius
is the maximum distance of a point from
centroid we terminate when the radius of
a new cluster exceeds the threshold
again we're not we don't want things to
overlap so when it crosses that
threshold and it's overlapping with
other data we stop
so let's look at divisive clustering
remember we went from the bottom up
now we want to go from the top down
divisive clustering approach begins with
a whole set and proceeds to divide it
into smaller clusters
so we start with a single cluster
composed of all the data points
we split it into different clusters this
can be done using
monotheistic divisive methods what is
monothetic divisive method and we'll go
backwards
and let's consider the example we took
in the agglomerative clustering to
understand this
so we consider a space with six points
in it just like we did before same
points we had before
and we name each point in the cluster so
we have in this case we just gave it a
letter value a b
c d e f since we follow top down
approach
and divisive clustering obtain all
possible splits into two columns
so we want to know where you could split
it here and we could do like a
a b split and a cdef split we could do
bce
adf and you can see this starts
generating a huge amount of data
a b c d e f and so for each split
we can compute cluster sum of squares
and we can see here the actually have
the formula out for us b
j 12 equals n one of absolute value of x
minus absolute value of x
squared so again we're computing all the
different distances in there squared
back to your kind of euclidean distances
on that and so we can actually compute b
and j between clusters one and two
and we have the mean of the cluster and
the grand mean
depending on the number of members in
the cluster and we select the cluster
with the largest
sum of squares let's assume that the sum
of squared
distance is largest for the third split
we had up above
and that's where we split the abc out
and if we split the abc out we're left
with the def on the other side
we again find the sum of squared
distances and split it into clusters so
we go from abc we might find that the a
splits into bc and d into e f
and again you start to see that
hierarchical dendrogram coming down as
we start splitting everything apart
and finally we might have a splits in b
and c
and then each one gets their own def and
it continues to divide until we get
little nodes at the end and every data
has its own point or
until we get to k if we have set a k
value
so we've kind of learned a little bit
about the background and some of the
math
in hierarchical clustering let's go
ahead and dive into a demo
and our demo today is going to be for
the problem statement we're going to
look at u.s
oil so a u.s oil organization needs to
know it cells
in various states in u.s and cluster the
states based on the sales
so what are the steps involved in
setting this problem up
so the steps we're going to look at and
this is really useful for just about any
processing of data
although i believe we're going to be
doing this in r today we're going to
import the data set
so we'll explore our data a little bit
there create a scatter plot
it's always good to have a visual if you
can once you have a visual you can know
if you're really far
off in the model you choose to cluster
the data in or how many
splits you need and then we're going to
normalize the data so we're going to fix
the data up so it processes correctly
we'll talk more detail about
normalization when we get there
and then calculate the euclidean
distance and finally we'll create our
dendogram so it looks nice and pretty
and we have something we can show to our
shareholders so that they have something
to go on
and know why they gave us all that money
and salary for the year
so we go ahead and open up r and we're
actually using our
studio which is the really it has some
nice features in it
it automatically sets up the three
windows where we have our script file on
the upper left
and then we can execute that script and
it'll come down and put it into the
console
bottom left and execute it and then we
have our plots off to the right
and i've got it zoomed in hopefully not
too large a font but large enough that
you can see it
and let's just go ahead and take a look
at some of the script going in here
it's clustering analysis and we're going
to work we'll call it mydata
and we're going to assign it in r this
is a symbol for assigning
and we're going to go read csv
read csv file and
put that in brackets and let's before we
go any further let's just look at the
data outside of r
it's always nice to do if you can
and the file is going to be called
utilities.csv
this would also be the time to get the
full path so you have the right
path to your file and remember that you
can always
post in the comments down below
and when you post down there just let us
know you want to connect up with simply
learn
so that they can get you this file so
you can get the same file we're working
on you can repeat it
and see how this works this is
utilities.csv it's a
comma separated variable file so it's
pretty straightforward and you can see
here they have the city
fixed charge and a number of different
features to the data
and so we have our ror cost load demand
cells
nuclear fuel cost on here and then going
down the other side we have u.s cities
arizona boston they have central us
i guess they're grouping a number of
areas together the commonwealth area
you can see down here nevada new england
northern
us oklahoma the pacific region
and so on so we have a nice little chart
of different data they brought in
and so i'm going to take that complete
path that ends in the utilities.csv
and we're going to import that file let
me just enlarge this all the way
upside an extra set of brackets here
somehow maybe i missed a set of brackets
this can happen if you're not careful
you can get brackets on one side and not
the other or
in this case i've got double brackets on
each side
there we go and then the magic hot keys
in this case
are your control enter which will let me
go ahead and run the script
and so i've now loaded the data and as
you can see i went ahead and shrunk the
plot since we're going to be looking at
the
window down below and we can simply
convert the data to a string
now all of us do this automatically the
first time we say hey
just put it all out as a string and then
we get this huge
mess of stuff that doesn't make a whole
lot of sense
so when you can see here they have you
can
probably kind of pull it together as
looking at it
but let's go ahead and just do the head
i will do the head of my data
there we go and ctrl enter on that and
the head shows the first
five rows you'll see this in a lot of
different scripts
in r it's you type in head and then in
brackets you put your data
and it comes through and lists the first
five rows as you can see below
and it shows arizona boston central and
it has the same columns we just
looked at so we have the fixed charge
the ror the cost the load the
d demand i'm not an expert in oil so i'm
not even sure what d demand is
cells i'm guessing nuclear how much of
it's supplied by nuclear
and the actual fuel cost
and then the different states that it's
in are different areas
and one of the wonders of r is all these
cool easy to use tools that are so quick
so we'll do pairs and
pairs creates a nice graph let me go
ahead and run this
uh whoops the reason it gave me an error
is because i forgot to resize it so let
me bring my plot way out so we can see
it and let's run that again
and you'll see here that we have a nice
graph of the different data and how it
plots together how the different points
kind of come together
this is neat because if you look at this
i would look at this and say hey this is
a great
candidate for some kind of clustering
and the reason is is when i look at any
two pairs
let's go down to say cells and fuel
costs towards the bottom right
and when you look at them where they
cross over you sort of see things how
they group together
but it's a little confusing you can't
really pinpoint
how they group together you could
probably look at these two and say yeah
there's pretty good commonalities there
and if you look at any of the other
pairs you'll start seeing some patterns
there also
and so we really want to know what are
the patterns on all of them put together
not just any two of them but the whole
setup
let me go ahead and shrink my this down
for just a second just a notch here
and let's create a scatter plot
and this is simply just use the term
plot in brackets
and then which values do we want to plot
and if we remember
when we looked at the data earlier let
me just go back this way
in this case let's go ahead and compare
two just two values to see how they look
and we'll do fuel cost in cells
and it's in my data so we'll let them
know which two columns we're looking at
next to each other
and it will open up our plot thing and
then go ahead and execute that
and we can see on those close up of what
we're just looking at in the
pairs and if i was eyeballing this i
would say oh look there's a
kind of a cluster up here of five items
and
this one it's hard to tell which cluster
would be with but maybe it's six you go
in the top one
and you have a middle cluster and a
bottom cluster maybe two different
clusters
so you can sort of group them together
fuel cost and the cells and see how they
connect with each other
and again that's only two different
values we're looking at so in the long
run we want to look at all
of them and then the people in the back
they sent me the script so we can go
ahead and add labels so with my data
text
fuel cost cells the labels equal city
position 4. these are numbers you can
kind of play with till they look nice
and oops again i forgot to resize my
plot it doesn't like having it too small
and we'll run that
i must type something in here oh i did a
lowercase d and they did a capital d
there we go
so now we can go in here and do this
with my data and you can see
a little hard to see on my screen with
all the different things in there
it plots the actual cities so we can now
see where all the cities are in
connection with in this case fuel cost
and cells
so we have a nice label to go with the
graph
and then we can also go ahead and plot
in this case let's do
oh the r o r oops
and we'll do that
also with the cells and do my data
remember to leave it lowercase this time
so we plot those two
we'll come over here and it's gonna i'm
surprised it didn't give me an error
and then we'll also add in the uh with
statement so we put some nice labels in
there
and it's going to be the same as before
except instead of doing the field cost
cells we want the r
cells and we'll execute that
oops and of course it gives me an error
because i shrunk it down
so let's redo those two again
there we go and we can see now we have
the ror
with cells and we'd probably get a
slightly different clustering here if i
was looking at these cities they're
probably different than we had before
but you could probably look at this and
say yeah these kind of go together
and those kind of go together but again
we're going to be looking at all of them
instead of just one or two
and so at this point we want to dive
into the next step we're going to start
looking at a little bit of coding
or scripting here
this is very important because we're
going to be looking at normalization
we put that in there normalization and
if you've done any of the other machine
learning
skills and setup this should start to
look very normal in your pre-processing
of data
whether you're in r or python or any of
these scripts we really want to
make sure you normalize your data so
it's not biased
remember we're dealing with distances
and if i have let's say the
ror is even look at this graph here on
the right
you can see where my ror varies between
8 and 14.
that's a very small variable and our
cells varies between four thousand and
sixteen thousand so you can imagine the
distance between four thousand and eight
thousand which is a distance of four
thousand
versus eight to 10 verses 2 the cells is
going to dominate
so if we do any kind of special work on
this
it's going to look at cells and it's
going to cluster them just by the cells
alone
and then ror might have a little tiny
effect of 2 versus four thousand
we want to level the playing field
turns out there's actually a number of
ways in script
to normalize so i'm just going to put in
the code that they put together in the
back for me and let's talk about it a
little bit
so we have z we're going to assign it to
my data
and it's go ahead and we're going to do
a little reshaping across all rows
or i mean across all columns so each of
the rows is going to have a little
reshaping there
and then we're going to get m which
stands for means
and we're going to apply it to my data
so again we want to go ahead and create
a
the most common variable in there
and then s is going to be sd stands for
standard deviation
so instead of just doing a lot of times
what they do with
normalization of data is we just reshape
the data everything between zero and one
so that if the lower end is eight that
now becomes zero and the upper end is
fourteen that now becomes
one that doesn't
help if it is not a linear set of data
so with this we're going to look for the
means and the standard deviation
for reshaping the data and that way the
most common values
now become the kind of like the center
point
and then the standard deviation is how
big the spread so we want the standard
deviation
to be equal amongst all of them and then
finally we go ahead and take z
and with the z we're going to reassign
it and we're going to scale
the original my data which we re shaped
based on
m and based on the standard deviation
and the 2 in here that just means we're
looking at
everything in kind of a x y kind of plot
and we can quickly run these control
enter control enter
control enter control enter so now we
have z which is a scaled version of my
data
and now we can go ahead and calculate
the euclidean distance
oops calcu there we go
and in r this is so easy once you've
gotten to here we've done all that pre
data processing we'll call it distance
and we'll assign this to
dist so d-i-s-t
is the computation for getting the
euclidean distance
and we can just put z in there because
we've already reformatted and scaled z
to fit what we want let me go ahead and
just hit enter on that
and i'm going to widen my left hand side
again i'm always curious what does this
data look like
so let's just type in distance which
will print the variable down below
oops i have to hit ctrl enter
and this prints out a huge amount of
information
as you can see just kind of streams down
there
and let's go ahead and large this
and i don't know about you but when i
look at something like this it doesn't
mean a whole lot
to me other than i see two three four
five six
and then you kind of have the top part 6
17 18
so imagine this is like a huge chart
is what we're looking at
and we can go ahead and use print oh
distance
digits
[Applause]
equal three and let's run that
also keep forgetting that it has to go
through the
graph on the right and we see a
different slightly different output in
here let me just open this up so we can
see we're looking at
and by cutting down the distance you can
start to see the patterns here if it's
looking at the different distances
so if i go to the top we know the
distance between one and two
one and three one and four one and five
one and six and then
two and three and so on obviously
distance between itself is zero
and it doesn't repeat the data so we
don't care to see two versus one again
because we already know the distance
between one and two
and so we have a nice view all the
distances in the chart and that's what
we're looking at right here
and it's a little easier to read that's
why we did the print statement up here
to
do digits equals three make it a little
bit smaller we could even just do digits
oh let's just do two see what that looks
like we might lose some data on this one
if it's uh
if something's way off but we have a
nice set up and we can see the different
distances and that's what we were
computed here between
each of the points and then the whole
reason we're doing this
is to get ourselves a nice dendogram
going a nice clustering dendogram
we'll do a couple of these looking at
different things
we'll take a variable hc.l and we're
going to assign it
h cluster and then distance
that easy we've already computed the
distances
so the age clustering does all the work
for us and let me hit enter on there
so now we have our hcl which is assigned
the h clustering
computation based on distances and apart
and then i'm going to expand my graph
because we would like to go ahead and
see what this looks like and we can
simply plot that
and hit the control enter so it runs and
look at that we have a really nice
clustering
dendogram except when i look at it
the first thing i notice is it really
shows like numbers down below
now if you were a shareholder and some
data
scientist came up to you and said look
at this this is what it means
you'd be looking at that going what the
heck does 3 9 14 19
1 18 mean so let's give it some words
there
so let's do the same plot with our hcl
hc there we go and let's add in
labels and this is just one of the
commands and plots
so we have labels equals my data
and then under my data we want to know
the city
and we'll have it hang minus one that's
just the instructions to make it pretty
so we'll run that oops i accidentally
ran just to hang my one let me
try that again there we go okay
so now you can see what it's done and
the hang my one turns it sideways that
way we can see
uh central which is central us and
kentucky
and we start to actually get some
information off our clustering
setup and the information you start
looking at
is that we put all the information
together
you probably want to look at central
american kentucky together
oklahoma and texas has a lot of
commonality as does arizona and southern
us
and you can even group all five of those
florida oklahoma texas arizona
and southern u.s these regions
for some reason share a lot of
similarities
and so we want to start asking what
those similarities are
but this gives us a place to look it
says hey these things really go together
you should be grouping these together as
far as your cells and what's what you're
doing
and then one of the things you might
want to do
is there's also we can do the dendogram
average
this changes how we do the clustering
so it looks very similar like we had
before and those are hcl we're going to
assign it
we're going to do an h cluster we're
still doing it on distance
oops distance and this time we're going
to set the method to average
so we can change the methodology in
which it computes
the values and before if you remember
correctly we did median
median's a little bit different than
means we did the most common one and
then we want the
average of the median and let's go ahead
and run that
and then we can plot and here's our hcl
oops there we go here's our hcl and i
can run that plot
and you can see this changed a little
bit so our way it
computes and groups things it looks a
little different than it did before
and let's go and put the cities back in
there and do the hang
control copy let me just real quickly
copy that down here
because we want the same labels
and again you can see nevada idaho pujet
i remember we were looking at southern
us and arizona
texas and oklahoma florida so the
grouping really hasn't changed too much
so we still have a very similar grouping
it's almost kind of flipped it
as far as the distance based on average
has
but this is something you could actually
take to the shareholders and say hey
look these things are
connected and at which point you want to
explore a little deeper as to why
they're connected because they're going
to ask you
okay how are they connected and why do
we care
that's a little bit beyond the actual
scope of what we're working on today
but we are going to cover membership
what's called a clustering membership on
there
and let's create a member we'll just
call it number one
oops there member dot one and we're
going to assign to this
we're gonna do cut tree
and cut tree
it limits it so what that means is i
take my
hc dot l in here
oops there we go dot l and so i'm taking
the cluster i just built
and we want to take that cluster and we
want to limit it to
just a depth of three so we go ahead and
do that
and run that one oops let me go run
there we go so now i've created my
member one
and then oops let me just move this out
of the way we're going to do
an aggregate and we're going to use z
remember z from above
and we're going to turn number one into
a list
and then we're going to aggregate that
together based on the mean let me go
ahead and
enter run that
so i did member l it's actually number
one
there we go
and if we take a look at this we now
have our group one
fixed charge and then all your different
columns listed there and most of them
should come up
kind of looking between zero and one but
you'll see a lot of variation because
we're
varying it based on the means so it's a
means the standard deviation
not just forcing it in between zero and
one
which is a much better way usually to
normalize your data than just doing the
zero one setup
and finally we can actually look at the
actual values
and the same chart we just did oops
i made a mistake on there with my data
there we go
okay and again
we now have our actual data instead of
looking at
just the if you looked up here it's all
between zero and one
and when we look down here we now have
some actual
connections and how far distance this
different data is
again because more of a domain issue in
understanding the oil company what these
different values means
and you can look at these as being the
distances between
different items so a little bit
different
view and you have to really dig deep
into this data
we really want you to take away from
this is the
dendogram and the charts that we did
earlier
and that is the cluster output and our
nice dendogram
so this would be stage one in data
analysis of the sales
again you'd have to have a lot more
domain experience to find out what all
the individual numbers we looked at mean
and what the distance is and what's
difference between central
america and kentucky and why they're
similar and why it
groups all of central kentucky florida
oklahoma texas arizona and southern us
together into one
larger group so i'd be way beyond the
scope of this but you can see how
we start to explore data and we start to
see things in here where things are
grouped
together in ways we might not have seen
before and this is a good start
for understanding and giving advice for
sales and marketing
maybe logistics city development there's
all kinds of things that kind of come
together
in the hierarchical clustering as you
begin to explore data
and we just want to point out that we
get three clusters of regions with the
highest cells
region with average cells region with
the lowest cells
again those are some of the things that
they clustered it around and you could
actually see where things are going on
or lacking you know it's this case
if you're the lowest cells no one wants
to be in the region of the lowest sales
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here